britains joint is joining the u.s.
effort to tighten security on commercial
airliners from some Middle Eastern and
North African countries passengers on
direct flights to the US from eight
countries will not be allowed to carry
on electronic devices larger than a
phone the British rules will apply to
flight from six countries authorities
say the new bands are in response to a
terror threat explosives concealed
inside a laptop blew up last year inside
a plane in Somalia Jeff pjs is in
Washington Jeff good morning good
morning the somalia explosive caught the
attention of US intelligence officials
last year it suggested the terrorist
groups had stepped up their efforts to
bring down a plane and we're testing new
approaches US officials have been
assessing how to respond to this type of
threat and CBS News has learned that in
the last two weeks the urgency to make
changes intensified US officials tell
CBS News the new airline electronics ban
is a byproduct of gathered intelligence
that concluded al-qaeda developed the
capability to hide explosives within
batteries that could fit in laptop
computers and tablets they are hoping to
avoid a repeat of a situation like this
one last februari in Somalia when a
bomber detonated an explosive concealed
in a laptop shortly after takeoff before
the explosion surveillance video shows
two airport workers in Mogadishu
affiliated with the terror group
al-shabaab handing the laptop explosive
to the bomber in a secured area of the
airport the White House maintains that
based on evaluated intelligence it was
necessary to enhance security protocols
the terrorist groups continue to target
commercial aviation and our aggressive
in pursuing innovative methods to
undertake their attacks the Department
of Homeland Security's new measure will
restrict flyers from eight
muslim-majority countries at 10
different airports from bringing laptops
tablets and other large electronic
devices with them on board airplanes the
British band will affect only six
countries we're dealing with thinking
predators here we're not dealing with
the static threat Frank salut Flo is a
former White House counterterrorism
official he says Great Britain may not
be the only
tree to follow the American ban on
electronics you can imagine the French
the Germans the Dutch you name it face
some of the same risks and and we'll be
asking some of the same questions the
former head of TSA John Pistole tells
CBS News the carry-on ban cuts in half
the opportunities a terrorist has to get
a bomb on board a plane but he and
others concede that this is not a silver
bullet Alex Jeff thank you